in 1928 a fungus contaminated a petri
dish and killed some of the bacteria
living in it famously Alexander Fleming
investigated the phenomenon and
discovered penicillin an accidental and
lucky discovery many scientific careers
are made up of serendipitous successes
and failures but it isn't all luck a
scientists productivity and ability
matter - so is it possible to predict
who will make an exceptional discovery
and when is a scientific career
predictable to answer these questions an
international team studied the research
publications of many scientists from
different disciplines
take for example Richard Fineman who is
awarded the Nobel Prize in Physics for
his work on quantum electrodynamics in
his career Fineman published 32 works in
Physical Review journals
scientists measure the impact of a
discovery by looking at citations that
is how many other scientists around the
world mention the discovery in their
work let's look at the number of
citations that fineman's works received
in the first 10 years after publication
his highest impact paper theory of the
Fermi interaction furthered our
understanding of the particle physics
behind radioactive decay and received
330 citations you can see that he
published two more highly cited papers
in his career in this way the team
reconstructed the careers of more than
20,000 scientists from disciplines
including neuroscience ecology physics
chemistry and economics all these
careers look different with valleys and
peaks of impact to identify outstanding
discoveries the team focused on the
highest impact publication by each
scientist shown here by the red dots
the data showed that scientists tend to
make major discoveries when they are
young
this finding matches previous research
on creativity for example the first line
here represents a career of 23 years
this scientist published his breakout
paper in year 5 the second line
represents a 14-year career with the
highest impact work published in the
first year but when the team examined
the reason behind early creative success
they stumbled across something that
surprised them scientists are simply
more productive when they are young
giving them a higher chance of producing
that big hit in their early years if we
ignore the timing and only look at the
position of the highest impact paper in
the sequence of a scientists
publications we see that the highest
impact paper can be with the same
probability anywhere in the sequence of
papers published it could be the first
publication it could appear mid-career
or it could be a scientists last work in
other words impact is randomly
distributed within a scientist body of
work regardless of discipline a results
the team named the random impact rule
but scientific careers are not entirely
random a scientists ability matters too
so the team developed a model to
untangle the effects of luck
productivity and ability they came up
with this equation C is the impact of an
individual publication P is luck while Q
captures a scientists ability to take an
idea and convert it into a high-impact
discovery each scientist has a unique Q
value which can be high like the
scientist on the left or low like the
one on the right luck or P fluctuates
throughout a scientists career
unsurprisingly great discoveries seem to
be the result of both luck and ability
or Q
as pastor said fortune favors the
prepared mind we might expect queue to
increase over the course of a career as
a scientist becomes more experienced but
it doesn't an individual's q-value seems
to stay constant this could make q a
more meaningful measure than currently
used metrics such as total number of
citations or the h-index
which do increase over time nevertheless
there are lots of questions
what exactly is q could we train
scientists to have high q-- and should
we use it to make decisions about
funding or an individual scientists
career there's plenty to discuss but
take heart with a bit of luck your next
project could be your most successful
one
you